[Music]
my
i'm going to be showing you how to cook
the best christmas lunch that you and
your family have ever had
we're going to be cooking the perfect
christmas starter smoked salmon with a
fresh and delicious fennel and apple
salad
suckling roast turkey with herb butter a
decadent chestnut pistachio and sage
stuffing
topped off with a rich apple and cherry
gravy
and all the trimmings mouth watering
spiced honey glazed carrots and parsnips
brussels sprouts with bacon and chili
perfect goose fat roast potatoes
and fantastic bacon-wrapped cocktail
sausages
and to finish it off a terrific
christmas trifle
[Music]
this is for everyone you don't need to
be a brilliant cook but a little bit of
preparation will make all the difference
so get ready because i'm going to be
telling you my top tips and sharing
those all important trade secrets
[Music]
how to buy the best turkey nice meaty
bird
how to get more bang for your buck
cheapest chips
and everything you need to buy for the
big day
stick with me and you'll be ready for
anything when the stuffing hits the fan
on christmas day
first things first the turkey now it
wouldn't be a proper christmas dinner
without a big
fat turkey always go for the best meat
you can afford and remember the more
mature the bird the better it tastes
so get a turkey that's lived a little
if we want to keep our local butchers on
the high street we have to use them
my grandfather was a butcher and as a
chef i know how important they are when
it comes to buying quality meat
lid gates in west london has been
thriving for 150 years
and is one of the most respected
butchers in the country danny lydgate
is the fifth generation of his family to
work there so he knows what matters when
it comes to buying a turkey
the golden rules of buying a christmas
turkey really make sure you get to a
good butcher make sure you know the
history of the turkey
if you're buying from a supermarket it's
best to avoid the frozen turkey
it's going to take ages to thaw out it
lose loads of liquid when you defrost it
you're never going to get the same
quality and succulents as you buy a nice
fresh bird
what you want to look for really is
avoiding a bird with bruising with torn
skin
you can see a lovely fresh bird here
it's got no markings the skins intact
nice meaty bird
[Music]
if you're feeding fewer people try and
buy a whole bird the smallest one
possible
this bird here would be great for a
family of three or four people
you're going to get the stark meat and
the lovely breast meat
if you were to buy a crown of the big
one you're only going to get the white
meat
it still gives you the whole bird effect
as well so you still get it for
christmas dinner
carving a bird
[Music]
next to make sure that christmas dinner
is special you must buy fresh herbs
and stock up on those essential spices
for my perfect christmas dinner you're
going to need
star anise cinnamon sticks chili
and vanilla you'll need chives for the
starter parsley and tarragon and thyme
for the herb butter
to go with a turkey and sage in the
stuffing
and they've got to be fresh that's what
makes the difference between a dinner
that's just
okay and one that will blow your socks
off
[Music]
spice boy stevie pal is an award-winning
26 year old chef
who runs the doc kitchen restaurant in
london's notting hill
stevie has traveled the world in search
of the best herbs and spices so he knows
exactly what to look for
when it comes to buying the best for my
cook along menu
stynis is a beautiful spice but it's
very strong in flavour
and we use it on pork or duck it has a
flavor that almost
cuts through the sort of greasiness of
some of the meats
what you need to look for when you when
you're buying it is that you're buying
whole star anise
that are not all broken and dusty and
that will be an indication that the star
needs
is quite fresh when a recipe calls for
chili flakes
what i tend to use is these little chili
flakes here
which are actually turkish moist and
oily and not too hot so you can use
quite a good quantity
it's almost like a coarse kind of smoked
paprika you can use them almost like you
use black pepper as another seasoning
cinnamon is the one that everyone
associates with christmas and what
you're looking for when you're buying
cinnamon
is soft sticks like this that you can
crumble in your hand
i think there's no real point buying
powdered cinnamon it hasn't got that
same kind of flavor it's
it's been ground a long long time ago
and it's lost that amazing vibrance that
you get when you just break a cinnamon
stick
i think in general these days there is
basically no excuse for using dried hair
especially a herb like parsley
which is kind of you know it just tastes
like old cut grass the smell is really
really unpleasant
you're better off buying a beautiful big
fresh
hearty bunch of parsley a bunch of
parsley like this from an ethnic shop
can cost you less than a pound whereas a
miserable
um sort of floppy thing that you get
from a supermarket it could be two quid
the important thing to remember when
you're cooking with herbs or spices is
to be confident
pack them up and throw them in things
use quite a lot of spices you just
really enjoy cooking with herbs and
spices so that
at christmas when you want everything to
taste really fantastic
you've got all these brilliant things to
sort of juice up your cooking
[Music]
back to the bird to make sure your
turkey is the tastiest
juiciest and the most succulent bird
you've ever had i'm going to be talking
you through
a herb butter this is something you can
do in advance the night before
you'll need butter flat leaf parsley
thyme and tarragon
chop the herbs and beat them into the
butter and don't forget to take the
butter out of the fridge first thing in
the morning so it's nice and soft when
you want to use it
now i'm not going all hue fernie wormy
on you but when it comes to vegetables
for my cooking
i demand the best and so should you it's
christmas
and you want this to be a meal to
remember so go local
get your veggies from a green grocer
nearby if you can if not
supermarket stuff is fine you just need
to know what to look for
rushton is one of britain's busiest
green grocers he's been in the trade for
26 years and supplies some of the
country's best restaurants and most
demanding chefs
including me so he definitely knows his
onions when it comes to buying your
christmas veg
important thing about your christmas veg
is keep it as seasonal as you can
so you're looking to buy things like
sprouts parsnips carrots
all fantastic seasonal veg packed full
of flavor
really inexpensive cheapest chips for
your roasties
maris piper really good potato if you
can
buy them loose you can look at them you
can feel them make sure there's no
blemishes on them
trust me they'll come up beautifully
nice and crisp on the outside
fluffy on the inside
when you get your sprouts there's
nothing difficult these regular sprouts
here
nice and green the most important thing
is make sure the bottom is nice and
clean and white
if you see it's brown it means that
they've been trimmed several days ago
and they're getting old you don't want
that you want them nice and fresh
tender sweet lovely tasting vegetables
carrots for your christmas dinner
again another really inexpensive veg get
something that's not too big like these
medium to small sized carrots nice and
sweet this time of year lots of flavor
these big boys here we know in the trade
as donkey carrots
for your christmas lunch it's a no-no
they're a little bit too hard
woody and they won't be very sweet
because they're an old carrot
another great winter veg the parsnip
don't get large ones just like your
carrots
they do have a woody core through the
center and if they're smaller
there'll be less wood inside them so the
rule is
use your eyes let your eyes be your
guide make sure your veggies nice and
fresh
don't get anything that's too big and
old you don't need pre-packaged goods
go and buy it loose christmas day the
biggest lunch of the year
make sure you enjoy it
if you're cooking along with me you
don't have to prep anything in advance
i'll be taking you through it step by
step so if you want to go commando
that's not a problem but if you have a
chance then prepping your veg
is a great way to get ahead and it'll
leave you more time to enjoy the morning
with your family
[Music]
to prep my luxurious spiced honey glazed
carrots and parsnips
peel and quarter the carrots and
parsnips and make sure they're roughly
the same size
put them on a tray and cut them with a
damp cloth
prepping the sprouts with bacon and
chili is easy even easier
if you buy your sprouts ready trimmed
don't bother crisscrossing them
just cut them in half right through the
core that way the sprouts stay together
put them in a bowl and cover them with
cling film
and last but not least to get your spuds
ready to make the perfect goose fat
roast potatoes
simply peel them and quarter them stick
them in a bowl of water
cover and put them in the fridge and
remember you can do this the night
before
or first thing christmas morning
another great way to grab yourself an
extra half an hour in bed
is to make the stuffing the night before
[Music]
roughly chop your chestnuts and add to
the sausage meat do the same with the
apricots and pistachios
next bunch the fresh sage leaves
together chop
and add to the bowl finally add an egg
to hold it together
and give it a good mix put the mixture
into a loaf tin
and really push it into the corners
cover it with cling film
and leave it in the fridge until you're
ready
don't worry if you haven't got the time
to prep anything before the big day
just preheat your oven to 220 degrees
and drag a tv into the kitchen
i'll be there to help you through the
cooking step by step
making sure you have a happy and a
delicious christmas
keep calm and carry on cooking
good morning happy christmas is your
oven on at 220 degrees
good let's go
[Music]
welcome to christmas cook along live
can't believe we're doing this thanks
for joining me on this
very very special day and we're at home
now the whole country
is cooking along up in manchester we've
got max beasley hello max happy
christmas
merry christmas garden how are you
absolutely sensational great to be here
on this lovely day
now it's a little bit colder than la who
are you cooking for today
well here we have my father hi god
nice to see you how are you and just
over here
he's great just over here my ma joanie
my uncle roger
hi joanie uncle howard roger lovely
lovely sister katie
howard katie good to see you max what on
earth has happened to your arms
well i know that you've got a bit of an
obsession with bex
i feel like the love is gone from me so
i've gone out got myself tatted up so i
can get embraced with you a little bit
more
looks like you got carried away with a
felt tip
lovely now are you feeling confident
about today
yeah i'm really excited actually some of
the ingredients look great i'm looking
forward to
trying the gravy out which looks
sensational and i'm really raring to go
good good good now over to two people
who know the only way to cook a perfect
christmas lunch
is to cook with me argent lydia happy
christmas
and now really good to see you uh
welcome uh all three of you i'm not too
sure if you can hear me probably but
ah how do you rate your cooking out of a
scale of one to ten
um you know what golden i've never
really cooked much in my life i've done
a bacon sandwich now and then but
i'm a quick learner and i'm excited i'm
gonna give it my own i think you're
gonna be quietly impressed
listen good luck with the cooking i'll
come back to you later on merry
christmas to all of you and good luck
right first things first we're gonna
make the most amazing herb butter for
the turkey okay
that's very easy but it guarantees your
bird won't be a dry one now
soft butter first thing we're gonna chop
the parsley and the tarragon now
this is so important okay bunch up the
tarragon and the parsley
don't worry about chopping it too finely
because you want all that flavor coming
out
over the turkey parsley in
tarragon in now a little bit of salt and
pepper
[Music]
merry christmas christmas how are you
guys haley
good to see you welcome come in and uh
president with little glitter brothers
very kind thank you for coming through
thank you thank you just in time to get
started on the turkey
it's fantastic please i'm going to take
your coats how are you i'm i'm
halftastic how are you
merry hoffman good to see you yes thank
you thank you sir now
darling how are you good thank you yes
good good good
are you well uh i'm hungry you're hungry
i'm hungry are you ready
i'm ready i'm hungry i'm not a good cook
but i'm hungry okay great so i'm right
yes
let's go through the kitchen darling
we're gonna catch up with you later
gorgeous dress
yes gorgeous dress good to see you all
right thank you
all right bye uh wow wow wow
um i'm ready good to see you good to see
you man yeah cheers
ah good to see you good to see you your
girlfriend is gorgeous i know i know
she's from wales
you have had a fantastic year haven't
you yes how could i not
an amazing judge britney's got talent
yeah yeah panto
yeah i'm doing um half the hook and
we're breaking all the records in
bristol they have a drum
and i'm staying in town we're going on
tour okay great um i saw a show called
an audience with
okay yes and we just kind of took that
format and we're doing an evening with
david hasselhoff and we go we started in
february a normal christmas day pb watts
would you be
selling it in california would you be
down in cardiff
on christmas yeah yeah you'd be doing
yeah
would you be with your family right yeah
have you got the welsh accent yet
i don't know the welsh science is like
reading in chinese
it's difficult it's very weird yeah
they're the nicest people in the world
you know that means though
yeah no no you don't know wreath yes
exactly yeah yeah good to see you both
now how is he at cooking
not very good we're gonna find out now
right you're gonna help me okay so all
right great give that butter a little
mix
okay now we've got some tarragon okay
okay and we've got some parsley all
right uh
darling i'd like you to take some time
what are we making so we're gonna make
some really nice herb butter for the
turkey
herb now pick off the thyme
why'd you always say it without the
arabic yes
you say h or h no you never use the h do
you no h
h h h so in there butter okay
parsley tarragon and some fresh thyme
now
this is going to go into the turkey
under the skin okay now the secret here
whoa
is
now the secret okay yes is to put that
butter
between the skin okay and this is the
hard bite you've got the easy bit
okay now just remove the skin very
carefully
now this is for me the secret that keeps
the bird really nice and moist
okay the skin is released from the
breast i want you
very carefully to take half the butter
and put on the left hand side another
half on the right hand side
on on the breast inside inside whoa
now i've never done one i don't look so
scared there's any butter there you go
wow just imagine imagine you're doing
christmas
imagine you're giving simon cowell a
quick massage no no let's not go there
i don't spread that nice in there okay
nice you know the other side i
understand
whoa this is very weird i suppose being
american it's almost like putting a sort
of baseball glove on your house yeah it
is
a big one better well done okay now okay
right underneath okay okay good good
that's good
you've done this before ah no i've never
stuck my hand in a turkey
that's great thank you good good
a little drizzle of olive oil okay
really important got the butter
underneath the skin that's going to get
the breast nice and moist but you want
that skin nice and crispy so
okay all right trust me the butter is
perfectly positioned if the hot can do
it anyone can do it let me tell you
salt pepper now turkey's in the tray the
most important part also is the gravy so
we'll start off with some
water into the tray and you'll
understand shortly whilst it's so
important for that inn
good cool now we put that together okay
straight over there thank you
okay which one top shelf there we are
this one no no no
one there we go this is okay okay good
menace now that's in for 220 for 10
minutes and then we'll get it nice and
brown we'll turn it down to 180.
good okay great better than hell's
kitchen so
now this yeah okay that's that's magic
that's in the oven we can relax a little
bit now
okay gonna make the stuffing okay um
how's your chopping
oh good good that's is that sharp uh it
is a sharp i love this so be careful
please
right chop the apricots yeah well thank
you i'll chop the
chestnuts okay stuffing before this
okay okay now
i see you've got a little sous chef
there so little sushi nice and
coarse smaller
straight in is this smaller than that
that's it no it's lovely okay okay okay
we're gonna take all day we're cooking
this christmas not next christmas now
right
apricots in chestnuts and pistachios in
i'm gonna season that with some fresh
stage
okay now well done well done well done
well done
straight a little bit of salt and pepper
oh my god good well done
you're incredibly fast okay that's
unbelievable
now one egg that's going to bind it to
only one egg
only one egg okay one egg do i mix that
around now you continue chopping i'll
mix it around
now okay good
now apricots in you can push them
straight in good man
excellent could be good now
haley when was the last time he actually
cooked for you the last one romantic
meal
yeah beans and eggs beans and eggs yeah
good okay now
stocking's done okay all right now
the secret here to get that in to the
tin
so turkey's in wow and the stuff in and
this is the stuffing this is the
stuffing
so it's a nice sort of pork savory
sausage meat now apricots chestnuts
and sagin that looks great okay good
now wow good okay there we go leave that
behind
so far so good now turkey is in the oven
stuff is ready if you're falling behind
here's a little ketchup for the ultimate
roast turkey and stuffing
remember take softened butter chop
parsley
tarragon and thyme and mix
season and massage under the skin
[Music]
pour on some olive oil season and add
water to the tray
to give the turkey a lovely rich crispy
brown skin put it in the oven
at 220 degrees for 10 minutes then spoon
over the juices
to make sure the meat stays succulent
cover
and roast 180 for the luxurious stuffing
chop apricots chestnuts
pistachios and sage and mix into the
sausage meat
stir in an egg and roast
roast turkey with her butter and
stuffing
perfect good job right max up in
manchester how's your stuff in
i'm very very together and calm and
obviously here we have the stuffing
have you got the foil on the turkey
that's the question
getting the foil on the turkey right now
unbelievable i'm in the right house i'm
definitely in my house
okay great we'll be back in a minute
right welcome back i'm here with the
huff
he's in a good mood the turkey's in the
event and my house smells absolutely
fantastic i hope yours does too
now it's time to make a delicious
starter smoked summer parcels with a
fennel and apple salad
big smoked salmon lover i love smoked
salmon okay we've got the nation
tweeting about your hands haven't been
cleaned properly
properly
follow me okay take a little espresso
cup yes okay now this is just a little
sort of
little bit of magic okay so take your
smoked salmon yeah and place it to the
bottom of the cup
and leave the sort of almost like the
little edges hanging over the side
okay the secret is to line the expresso
cup with a smoked salmon wow
okay just like that lining lining
what's gonna happen we're gonna make a
little smoked salmon mousse okay max
keep up with us now please the rest of
everybody else in the country keep up
too
push them down okay so it's almost like
a little sort of
almost like a little sort of buttercup
okay now while you do that that's lovely
nice i've got my cream cheese here all
right okay i'm gonna add
a nice tablespoon of horseradish that'll
zest it up
okay some creme fraiche that'll give it
the tartness as well for inside
the smoked salmon a little touch of
pepper and a smidgen of salt because the
smoked salmon is naturally seasoned
that's good i've never seen you work so
fast
all right okay now chop up a couple of
pieces of salmon okay add that to the
bowl that gives a nice little bit of
texture
inside that mousse now from there
into the bowl and then grate a little
bit of lemon zest
so it's nice and fresh okay awesome so
we're gonna mix that up
and then just very quickly chop up some
chives now that's gonna give it sort of
almost like a little sort of oniony
flavor can you mix that for me please
david thank you um are you a big foodie
do you enjoy
yeah i just i want to take a lesson and
learn how to do this this is a great
favorite foods i want what do you enjoy
eating well i love smoked salmon i love
turkey i love steak i love
i love i love pasta nice what yeah what
uh what don't you eat um i'm not a big
coconut fan oh really
yeah that's awesome there's no coconut
today okay good excellent all right
great have you got a big medallion under
there
no under there nice microphone i was
okay yeah
you've been pumping out in the gym well
no i work out you know
good man right from there all right all
right
okay um i want you to spoon that in
okay all right here's a spoon now get
the back of the spoon okay and push it
down in a way that sort of almost fills
up
that cup all right touch more than
everyone will be generous christmas oh
my god
now can you still fit into those
baywatch shorts yeah
yeah i can still fit into them yeah i
still run into slow motion
yeah i have a walker outside though now
haley only been 27 can you remember
baywatch
a little bit our first question was uh
who do you play on baywatch i said
you're perfect for me
just push that down like that are you
going to make this thing disappear
not yet he's coming dynamo is arriving
shortly now just push that in there and
that's going to sit in the fridge nicely
wow let's do another awesome
yeah okay pull it up again yeah nice
good
good good good okay now the secret about
these they set in the fridge
okay literally 60 minutes
in the fridge they will set uh max how
you getting all these little parcels
going on really well mate actually
they're all they're all prepared
obviously
and now i'm putting some salmon bits
into the mascarpone
and all the all the gear here over here
max
don't start drinking yet please okay
good
now okay wrap them over okay
push them down so they set really nice
okay how are you doing
he looks
debbie you're absolutely right arch come
on wakey wakey okay now please put your
kettle on
and during the ads i want you to peel
your pears and to chop the sprouts like
this
there's the core put the core on the
board and slice them in half that way
they stay together now lots of you
texting and worried about the actual
cooking time for the turkey please don't
worry it's on average 30 minutes per
kilo and then at the end if you can let
it rest
for 45 minutes minimum to an hour even
better but rest assured i'm with you
every step of the way okay
now time to make the most amazing
dessert it is the perfect alternative to
a traditional christmas pudding
now if you'd like you can do both trifle
excited yes very very okay good good now
would you like whip up the cream for me
please yes okay
is this it's a traditional whipped cream
before
it's a traditional english dessert haley
you know what trifle you grew up with
trifles right
you love trifles good now um grenadine
in
okay have you ever taken the triple
before no never okay
i think i may have but um now gas on
okay water into the pan we're gonna melt
the chocolate now the most important
thing is here we're gonna make it like
it's called a little bain marie okay
break up the chocolate
so we can melt that quickly okay
whiskey's doing well
is this whipped okay good now you do it
under water oh excuse me
[Music]
oh merry christmas come in how are my
daddy
great good to see you welcome to the mad
house well thank you very well the hob's
here
really yeah just seen his car did you
see the car did that take you back
uh yeah can you tell from me thank you i
look gorgeous are you well thanks i am
good to see you come on in please please
please straight down
good to see you hey hey dude nice to be
here
don't leave me here let me introduce you
to the huff hi
halfway i am the most amazing
[Laughter]
have you seen my big fat gypsy wedding
oh yes i have extraordinary this lady
makes all the dresses wow fantastic
fantastic all right enjoy it yes all
right yes i'm i'm i'm whipped up
i yeah i'm whipped up yeah i trust okay
there's no uh sort of gypsy weddings on
christmas day right
uh no it's a day okay that's the only
day um there we are that's right oh
thank you
so much good to see you i'm gonna help
you with the trifold i'd love to uh
would you be so can't just cut some of
these pears
okay slice the pears and put them into
there please into the grenade
excellent
[Music]
now our turkey is in the oven our smoked
salmon parcels are chilling in the
fridge
and a delicious dessert is halfway there
um max and ours
are you basting your turkeys
i've been basting the turkey uh i've
made a mistake with the uh of the cream
on the trifle is a split i've
i've done too much of that on it oh no
come on man you've over whipped your
cream come on you've turned it into
butter now it's christmas day max
all those courses
i know i should have gone to your school
boom can you give your dad
a glass to drink that wine looks like
he's swinging from the bottle
yeah do you want a glass for that one
very good
are you still doing all the work you
know what golden i was stressing out
earlier i was really panicking but now
i've had a little drink and relaxing i'm
really getting into the swing of things
now baby
gordon here is useless mommy's doing
everything for him
i'm actually doing everything when
you're not on camera he doesn't actually
do anything and then he goes like that
when you're back on camera debbie did
you give him that jumper for christmas
dad's going heavy what a shame okay
i can't believe that jumper's been
knitted uh lydia what did he get you for
christmas
no what am i going to give james to
christmas um
okay that'll be enough
it's a family show come on oh he's
kissing the mother-in-law
god bless him right time to make the
custard okay for the trifle um therma be
sick i'm pleased to separate the
eggs i need the egg yolks in there okay
um cream
so egg yolks in there don't you put the
whites in there oh you can wash your
hands thank you
now this is very special okay this is a
fresh vanilla pod
we're going to cut that in half okay now
the secret here is just to take out all
those vanilla seeds
okay do not get tips from half had to
wash his hands please
he's already been told off this morning
on twitter now vanilla in i can't get
that cream should i show you a quick way
yeah come on so you get the egg like
that
crack it over your hands okay and then
separate the yolk like that six in there
please danny thank you
good come on don't look so scared
it's only an egg cream in can you give
that little whisk please
yeah i've got the freshness hot little
smell of that that is amazing i mean
incredible
whoa what is this now what's the
largest dress you've ever made thermal
what is this um the one
the heaviest yeah in terms of three four
stone
24 stone yeah how does somebody walk
wearing that they don't they don't she
had wheelies on you know them little
trains
with wheels in the bottom a dress that
had wheelies on well
if you said wheelies on and she had a
dress that is extraordinary
24 stone and i mean what color was it
it's white they're always white they're
always wise so they never go for sort of
cream pink
navy no always wait they've got to be
white
are we putting in
[Laughter]
thank you very much don't you like my
shirt not really no i'm
sorry about that do you have that moment
when you think oh my goodness i mean
they don't like the dress i better get
out of here i fear for my safety
um i always have that feeling before
they come back or if they don't like it
yeah but
they always have a touch up tonight
um the whole documentary was a huge hit
right
yeah yeah and it was just a sort of a
great insight for the nation to see
how they lived because it was yeah it
was extraordinary why do you think it
was so
successful i think everybody because
they're so secretive nobody knows
nothing about them and
it was just like a little insight into
their whales i found the
dating scenario fascinating when a guy
likes a girl
they grabbed somebody yeah have you been
grabbed no
haven't been grabbed often
does paddy ever grab you no no never
paddy's lovely
paddy's lovely right give that a little
mix you've got the strawberries
no why are you in shape trust me uh good
creams come to the bowl got the vinegar
that's gonna infuse it eggs corn flour
that helps to thicken
the custard okay gonna put a little bit
of cream in there first
okay please continue whisking okay okay
good man now
um so traditional christmas would be
turkey turkey
yeah all the trimmings all the trimmings
yeah uh large family
yeah i've got four kids and all their
partners as well they all come
wow well well unbelievable uh
traditional christmas view would be what
in l.a typical christmas with me yeah
what would you be doing no boo
no no no no my family would be turkey
and stuffing
cranberry and mashed potatoes and my
mother made a special dish which was
green beans with cheese
covered in corn flakes you know kind of
like all groton it's fantastic it
started off nice but then you put
cornflakes on top
it's fantastic seriously yes yes
unfortunately she's not here to help
but um and i can't cook but unbelievably
good and
cornflakes on top of green beans and it
tastes good yes very good wow my
favorite that was great
um and panda's going well this year
panto's going great we're breaking all
box office records there's still tickets
off the hook and uh shout out to all my
panto cats
they are unbelievable people and we're
in bristol till january 8th
um fantastic now that custard is
thickened up okay
you can see them just give that little
whisk now
that needs to set now and get really
nice and cool and it smells
really nice and fragrant light
unbelievable
incredible sounds i'm gonna put that
tube in the fridge no at home
okay to get nice and cool nice
uh now what happened to this we'll use
that later there's someone else i'd like
to talk to because this is a very
special moment
yes it's christmas day and we've got our
very own christmas cook-a-long baby
born earlier this morning please pass me
the tablet thank you
right jennifer um first of all
merry christmas congratulations to you
and stuart
and i believe you had an early christmas
present at 1
28 a.m this morning yeah that's it
and how much does he weigh eight pounds
four ounces
wow what a whopper congratulations um
have you decided on the name gordon
sounds great
james we've gone for jack
patrick andrew wow jack
patrick andrew
wooden incredible and not even a little
gordon slipped in the middle as a second
name no
incredible
um now had you not given birth um early
this morning at 128. would you be
cooking along jenny
i would yeah definitely you look amazing
yeah extraordinary um and stuart a very
proud dad and
a new stunning baby jack
um i've got a little present for you
there as well
look now
i was born on christmas day born to cook
along um
enjoy the cook-off jenny shirt and jack
congratulations merry merry christmas
yeah wow how fantastic
christmas baby lovely amazing right i
will see you in a minute
amazing welcome back merry merry
christmas to you all hope you have a
great day
so far now
[Music]
i'm absolutely fantastic have you having
a good one already we're having a crazy
one this morning yeah
yeah hustling over whipping the cream i
got that texture me last night saying
could i come and help
please please please please what do you
want me to do um
we're gonna do some a little pigs in
blanket little chipotle
they're great i'm feeling great last
time i saw you was
many many moons ago in london now you
look thinner right and i've lost about
11 stones since i last you've lost my
stone you've lost my weight
really that's incredible really i mean
absolutely you look fantastic yeah what
are you used to
i do you know the best year in that
flavia
yes i love which camera on say could you
say something in italian to flavio
natale bonatar okay
i love you why'd you hear
me
so rumor has it then you knew how would
he come that was the past rumor
stop it could everybody come down
william
when you came out that cannon honestly i
peed my pants
that was extraordinary did it hurt no no
but you're doing what you did to your
parents didn't hurt me
um i came out that cannon although i was
lying on a
little tea tray yeah in fact what i laid
on was as big as that everyone
and then it sort of flew through wembley
like that to that great number and then
i had a sumo
i need some help i need some help i need
some help yes right time to make some
pigs in blanket okay and this is
delicious really right
you can name this afternoon come on come
on
right take your restaurant bacon get
your little chicken okay and roll
nice and tight okay there you go this is
a bit like
me on coming out the cannon isn't it the
same shape
come on you look great uh
these are delicious a little bit more
okay you're more
he's packing him in he's packing the
sold out show
um now are you still dancing i am still
dancing
i just love it i mean you know when i
when i
a couple of years ago gordon i decided
to go back to showbiz because that's my
roots
musical theater and i'd always wanted to
do strictly but i was too fat i was
bordering on 27 stone
seriously and um i decided a couple of
years back
to lose the weight go back to what
i think in life what you tend to do is
you do too much of what other people
want you to do and not enough of what
you want to do
yeah and so i went back to showbiz did
some fantastic
wonderful performances i went up to an
aborns theatre in scarborough
did a great show there um then
locally in north wales oh yeah daddy
flowers
now with that welch now we've gone from
italian
dolly flower blue in there with us i
can't speak welsh i mean
but i did that i did a midsummer night's
dream in north wales and then
strictly called and i tell you the best
thing ever
it not just wonders personally in terms
of losing weight but it did bring you
back from the brink in the way that it
shut you out but yeah but it brought me
back
in doing something i loved to do
astrology was only ever a hobby garden
it was never meant to be my job
yeah where is this but didn't you find
it a romantic thing to do did you think
it was
just my i mean all that wonderful music
but i mean all the pro
dancers i mean you know i've heard a
text this morning from aliona who of
course went on and won it
and um it's just i'm just so happy i
thought you're going to dress up in the
game
where is it well that's up in milton
keynes because i'm doing panto there but
i finished last night but i'm going back
for three nights
i mean panto who are you playing who's
your uh i'm playing genie at the camp
sorry the lamp and um and
then flav and i are going to be leading
the new year's day parade through london
oh wow
and i think i'm in that gold suit though
well that's amazing the house
dog's here as well he's in panto he's
behind you
are you ready
okay now the most important part is to
get some color on those sausages
put them in the oven for 25 minutes okay
in a couple of minutes
we're going to make a fennel and apple
salad to go with our delicious smoked
salmon parcels
okay so whilst the ads are on you need
to slice your fennel really thinly three
fingers one in front two behind
cut the fennel bowl in half and just let
the knife
do the work up and down okay ah i hope
you're paying attention
wakey wakey hello no thank goodness
debbie's there
come on we're always paying attention
[Music]
slice your fennel please we pay
attention
i've done it already
he's already sliced it i don't think you
have sliced it okay great
be careful when slicing see you in a
minute right welcome back now it's time
to get the stuffing
in the oven this house smells delicious
how are you doing i'm doing fine i was
just looking in the
in the refrigerator look in the
refrigerator right doing anything okay
the drink's on the table we don't need
to go in the fridge those are his drinks
okay now we're going to finish off that
delicious christmas starter okay your
fennel should be sliced so it should be
nice and crisp as well
add some capers into the fennel okay
russell come and help me please sir
yeah i know you love getting the kitchen
put the phone down and come and help
what you want me to tell everyone about
his tour
i want you to pick some parts i don't
know where he's going you know where
he's going
to pick some parsley and put it in there
for me please thank you
you're here to cook not to tweet those
very
very clean hands everyone right so we
can dress the salad okay a little bit
olive oil salt pepper
okay and a little zest okay of lemon
okay a little bit
now from there fab okay now i love this
smell no that's fine that give it a
little mix up and then from there i'm
gonna take the apple do you want the
skills
no just the knife
merry christmas
uh yes it does good to see you both come
in come and come in thank you thank you
very much um is christmas a big
difference in fennel
yeah yeah yeah very much brilliant
[Music]
brilliant
merry christmas all right there you are
right baby
okay all right all right what's
happening brother nice to meet you
um please do that no no no no
i've got some experts here now oh yeah
um
just hold that other side there like
that yeah and give that a little grace
no worries watch your fingers please of
course okay
who normally does the cooking i'm going
to be honest
i'm like serious yeah seriously so
it's the man right yeah thank you um
and how romantic is he around christmas
so is this year i've been following you
both on twitter
congratulations you just got engaged yes
yeah yeah please keep your hands off my
trifle
was it a traditional proposal to get
down on one knee he doesn't have to do
it
um it's a little bit big so there's a
bit sedentary
from there as well you have to show that
this is not a smart smile
did it come as a surprise did he sort of
catch you um
no i don't know i mean we i kind of
mentioned it
um a few a while yeah hinting a bit yeah
then uh it just got that kind of that
magical moment where it had to happen
yeah
the documentary was amazing seven dwarfs
absolutely loved yeah
um why do you think the nation fell in
love with it because it's real
don't you know it's kind of real
emotional it's educational as well yeah
and what was it like all being together
in that house i mean yeah
was it nightmare no we had a great laugh
no it's wicked wicked wicked yeah really
good
would you do the other one no you put
that in there okay we knew in particular
because we didn't know how we were going
to be you know living together for seven
weeks because we don't actually live
together yeah
and um it worked out for the better
right good
and max you paid the dwarf uh grumbly
is he's crumbly in real life does he
have any comments no
seriously seriously he's a pussycat
right yeah
it's lovely but what i love about you
more than anything you're almost like
that sort of alpha male you're
sort of standing there not taking it
from anybody
like almost like a mini gordon yeah you
know it has to be done and you know
are you like that all the time or it
just depends on what company you're in
no no no no you know it's a way of life
isn't it you know
i've had to kind of grow up dealing with
kind of certain things so
you learn to kind of that was the
fascinating thing about the documentary
in terms of what it showed
how good it was and the message you got
out there did you still get grief
no no no no it's i tell you the
documentary has been nothing but
positive
um
carrot max karen you know our names and
stuff
instead of like oh look at those cute
people okay
now we met one of britain's youngest
people this morning baby jack 1
28 this morning let's talk to britain's
oldest man
sir reverend reg dean
first of all merry christmas you are 109
years old
extraordinary merry christmas sir
amazing and thank you so much for
joining us and i know um
i mean you're just extraordinary you've
survived two world wars you've seen
24 prime ministers um my question to you
is how many turkeys have you eaten
well i've been a vegetarian nearly 50
years
many churches so you're telling me
reverend that the secret to a long life
is being a vegetarian
yes
i'm in trouble straight away uh
sir what does christmas mean to you
me to me the coming of jesus christ into
the world
with a message of hope extraordinary now
we have a very
talented researcher uh matt
um he's on my team and he's up there
cooking along with you matt
good to see you that's your grandson are
you proud of him
yes i'm very proud of it he's very good
to me
and i like him very much brilliant uh
congratulations are you looking forward
to these smoked salmon parcels
are you looking forward to the starter
yeah
brilliant um 24 prime ministers
have come and gone do you have a
favorite
yes wow
okay great well listen uh best wishes uh
enjoy lunch
and um have a very very happy christmas
thank you extraordinary unbelievable
you enjoy that right welcome back now
it's time to take the foil off the
turkey now the most important part take
that off
okay and just get that back in there
to get really nice and crispy that is
looking good absolutely
delicious now time to serve these
delicious
can we give them out now yeah i'm sure
hungry at home so
pasties are long tinny will do the
honors take one and pass them along
please my daddy
nice crispy you got them good don't drop
them jack
ladies first please
sorry sorry sorry you know i'm bleeding
um ladies and gentlemen
all of us he's the heart hey these are
the ones we made
they're fabulous good good um
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
oh my goodness
[Music]
hey merry christmas merry christmas
welcome thanks for having me good to see
you
thanks for dressing up are you good
are you well it's like a shirt it's like
a shirt and a
sort of festive uh nice um do you fancy
a little piggy blanket
why not there everyone daniel is in the
house
are you good i'm very good before we
start actually i don't know there's a
present for you i don't need to open it
yet
i'm going to save it for later on yeah
okay keep it somewhere safe it feels
like a jumper
i'll put it over there um are you a uh
big fan of pigs in blanket i like pigs
and blankets should we do it
please yeah yeah uh right you're gonna
show us a little uh christmas uh
little christmas trick mate yeah let's
start off um
i'm gonna put my finger blanket for now
yes good yeah yeah definitely
right let me try something can you get
me an empty bottle anything's about like
a
sort of just a small bottle yeah
okay come around guys um
right so the bottle let's try
yes watch this
you've had the most amazing year haven't
you it's been pretty good
you've walked along pigs in blankets at
christmas
sorry i couldn't be at home i'm coming
little amazing
now granddad was a big influence for you
right he means a lot to you and he was
the man that sort of
got you out there yeah he got me into
magic um kind of to get out of a bit of
trouble with some bullies
they were putting me in a wheelie bin
throwing me down the hill every day
after school
and he showed me a way to take away
that's terrible and
i've actually got gunpowder on my neck
so he's always watching over my shoulder
wow bless him and that made a big
difference in terms of what you did
to sort of show them a trick that got
them the bullies on your side and almost
you sort of disappeared out that scene i
think i scared them a little bit
what did you show i'm not a big guy
particularly but you know they always
get um
should we try it on you or me jack do
you mind
okay okay so just um
travis you know you're i'm much bigger
now and you're a lot bigger than the
bullies were
yeah but we'll try anyway yeah right so
just i want you to take your hands like
this and just
underneath and just lift me up i don't
wear that much
so you can lift me right yes it's not
that difficult no i want you to get
ready to lift me yeah
yeah so put your hands over there you're
not gonna need me the goonies no no okay
all right
just look at me yes just lift me again i
should feel heavier
[Laughter]
that's scary now the half's got a penny
on welcome back okay now it's time to
glaze your stuffing with some apricot
jam
and then put it put it back got the
taliban in the kitchen and then put it
back in the oven
now uh i would like you please russell
you said your two favorite ladies
yes i thought it was your three they're
seriously upset
you know what i'm having the best
christmas morning for a long time i
love this man he's gorgeous
[Laughter]
unbelievable don't ever hug a man with a
knife uh a little glaze
of jab just remember that when i leave
the house yeah okay great
right what am i doing now uh i'm ready
you're okay you're ready ready okay
a couple of tablespoons i've got jam
right okay veg um take the other side oh
okay now from there slice down good
just an angle so you use knives lots of
times good well
in half i'll do the past tips okay
okay great deal all right so not the
whole jar just a couple of tablespoons
it smells amazing in here unbelievable
that's me
good now russell please please be kind
to put it back into the oven
so blaze that's enough no that's enough
too much uh dynamo a little bit of
christmas magic for us
yeah what we got a couple minutes all
right let's do this watch your fingers
looking lovely
wow anyone anyone you want show
everybody
you focus on the colors so focus on the
palette
everybody everybody is
halfway down watch this your idea
oh my goodness
wow wow wow wow uh who taught you that
one granddad
that's just me that's just you yeah
unbelievable have you got yourself
credible no no no no no no no okay no no
no no i'm just cleaning i'm going to
watch your hand again we are getting
into so much trouble tweeting across the
nation please wash your hands
i'm sorry don't know let's be honest
you're more like
sort of david blaine than paul daniels
right i'm more like dynamo
yeah who was your big inspiration
growing up um it was my grandpa totally
honest like he was the only kind of real
magical role model that i looked up to
over the years i've seen ambergris like
you know i was with david copperfield in
vegas recently
penn teller legends you know david
blaine amazing
you know i'm just a big fan of magic in
general incredible
have you got another miracle planned for
next year i've got a few things
i'm working on i'm pretty sure you'll uh
definitely get to see him
okay now it's time to get your delicious
turkey out of the oven now
well done so far we have taken a huge
weight
okay off your shoulders now turn
the oven back up to 220. you'll need
that for the potatoes but look at that
wow that is amazing now
we've got some very exciting news we've
got another baby
ryan marshall would like to congratulate
his friend brett harvey on becoming a
father this morning
unbelievable blimey one born every
christmas minute fantastic news
right now turkey out okay the secret
here
is we're gonna get a lot of capricorns
out there tilt that
that looks painful till the turkey out
you want those roasting juices i'll
explain now why
um there we go wow max can i have a look
at your turkey please
what does that mean
max what are you doing sitting down come
on we're live
show me your turkey max there we go
no you're not gonna get it okay no
ah show me your turkey please
that looks much much better than i
expected
um and the good news is the turkey's got
a real tan not a fake e6 tan
well done okay
right the turkey's resting okay so trust
me you guys have done brilliantly well
now we're gonna make the gravy and you
know there's no point in having a
delicious moist turkey unless you've got
an amazing gravy so
just tilt russell
and just tilt it from side to side
you'll get all the fat from at the top
and all those juices will sink to the
bottom now
from there put the tray okay on
okay to the hob now get a little whisk
uh halfway give that a little whisk for
me please
i'm just gonna nip those little wings
off here
okay tell us about it excellent thank
you give that a little whisk
nice now brilliant um
could you jack you put the potatoes in
please kettle in
okay i put the potatoes into the pan
good man salt and off we go
good man right give that a little whisk
excellent well done turn the gas on a
little bit of salt well done jack
now give that a good scrape this is
where it's really important to make a
perfect gravy
a couple tablespoons of apple juice okay
apple juice in
nice it's got all the little trimmings
from the turkey got a little bit of
wings okay
from there christmas would not be
christmas without
sherry touch a show in there okay
nice nice nice nice turn that gas up
absolutely
now to thicken the gravy that's the bit
everyone sort of panics about
okay i'm gonna take a little knob of
butter and some flour
okay now from there just give that a
little mix bring it together almost we
call it a sort of bermanier but
basically it's flour
a touch of salt okay and
mix that up nice now don't know jibber
cook
um when i get chance yeah i'm not the
best cookie he doesn't have to just
magic set up
i'm pretty amazing with a microwave i'm
not gonna lie seriously what kind of
food you love eating
what's what's your favorite my grandma's
calling me fashion a big yorkshire
pudding
i really yeah it's the best wow and
you're that size how do you keep that
size
eating food like that corned beef hash
and a yorkshire pudding
hp sauce big octopus yeah it's been
awesome everything
nice nice nice touch
you're doing a good job then half all
right yeah a little bit more of a wing
in there i want to sort of
use these little bits that makes the
gravy absolutely delicious
now from there a little touch of chicken
stock
it smells incredible right
jack put the little lid on there bring
it up to the ball yes now
that's good that is my favorite
brilliance i like drinking
amazing night rider now cook off cook
off ah incredible yeah right
give that a nice whisk then from there
okay the bermania in now this thickens
the gravy
okay and see what happens it stops it
from going lumpy but more importantly
the flavor
uh jack you part of those spoons behind
please have a little taste cook the
seasoning
thanks bud and for me the gravy
is as important as the turkey thanks bud
jump in half what do you think russell
have a little taste please
ah please jump in right here we go
dynamo have a little taste
my christmas magic mmm now oh my god i
tell you what it is
very cool amazing amazing amazing
nice beautiful isn't it good right is it
as good as that hatch
[Music]
by the way thank you very much what are
you expecting a little bit always in the
house everybody
[Laughter]
now we've got a beautiful blue sky yeah
that's 16 degrees outside you've got a
jumper on wellington where have you been
where have i been yeah oh i came down
from southampton today okay
so colder down there it's more seaside
good a little muddy
uh a little bit muddy a little bit muddy
yeah good good good
early christmas present this morning uh
it was it was actually it wasn't but i
did um
i it's my favorite jumper and i've got a
couple of christmases ago it doesn't
have a squeaker
are you upset wearing that jumper upset
well you used to go out with philip
green's daughter so you could be in
barbados right now sat on the beach
it could be i'm happy that i'm here you
happy birthday amazing
amazing amazing amazing cool right we're
going to make some stunning rice
potatoes okay
um they have been part boiling okay so
i'm good at potatoes are you going to
potatoes
now just drain them off okay they've
been part boiling literally six or seven
minutes and then back onto your
board give them a little shake yeah okay
this is the important part okay give me
a little show tell me about this ah
okay good a little seasoning salt and
pepper
you put some salt pepper in there for me
good thank you
now from there a little touch of
semolina
that's what's going to get this yeah
that's what's going to get them really
nice
semolina and crispy okay revelation
please don't get any hair in my potatoes
i won't i promise okay all right give me
a little shake now okay all right
semolina's from a plant isn't it that's
right in thailand
in thailand that's right um food
now kind of foods um you love eating
what is it
kind of foods i love eating i love
english english foods i love game
okay uh fish big sushi fan eating
sushi and game wise game wise grass bit
of pheasant bit of grass
you should um friends of mine do really
um and
go into their lovely country houses and
uh they like
kill deers and stuff
you're actually made in chelsea were you
born in chelsea no i grew up in
southampton who's that i do you live in
chelsea though uh but yes i do i live in
my okay
whereabouts uh behind chelsea football
club nice
nice nice nice now give me a little
shake
what the hell i don't know if you look
there there you go okay good
do not burn yourself on the goose side
so we've got goosebumps in there that's
going to make the potatoes absolutely
delicious
the semolina is going to make it really
nice and crunchy you season them nicely
i'll pop them into the oven what's the
difference between goose and duck just a
bigger bird like
a backpack there's so much more i mean
so much more fat
there is no duck right they're gonna get
nicer more for your money
definitely now give them a little shake
okay and then get them
into the oven make sure that opens up to
220. okay welcome back now it's time to
finish our trifle
uh thank you for washing your hands the
wrap hasn't been doing well at all
now we're going to slice the swiss roll
okay the secret
behind here half i need you and some of
those mussels whipping the cream please
thank you
um ollie yes you slice that nice and
thinly okay
okay just down like that because i'm
gonna line okay
the trifle yeah okay now just watch
you don't cut yourself okay okay and
watch those nails
russell crystal bowl not crystal ball i
don't
use crystal balls you don't use crystal
balls i've got crystal balls and i don't
use them
you don't have to watch this what do you
want me to do i want you to take this
roll and line it all the way around
yes please thank you yeah um do you cook
at home ollie do i um
i order in a lot but i go out quite a
lot but i do um
yeah cook a little bit mm-hmm i like
trying to make sushi no i i like
oh that's quite complicated that you
know it's quite fun though yeah it's
very fun man
it's a great second date i love these do
you know i love trying biggest food
disaster olly what would you say
disaster getting chester my flatmate to
cook that's good oh really is horrific
seriously you
is that the very dry one that's it
lovely madeira that you can have
that's nice try and line it all the way
around the top
brilliant is it sherry you put in try
sherry i got a bit pissed off
on a trifle last night
now look at those pears we've drained
the pears they'll be soaking in
grenadine okay
[Music]
hello how are you doing a thousand miles
an hour okay
yeah sure right now we're going to start
assembling the trifold okay
yeah right start off with first now
that's that customer
made earlier isn't it that one with the
vanilla that's right
that's right i love this
right some pear in there please let's do
it together all together yeah just half
of those pairs in there so i'll put it
in the fingers yes please
they'll be washed um we're gonna do it
in the lab what have you done with that
have you made them red we've soaked them
in grenadine they're very organic
delicious now from there
jermaine defoe good morning merry
christmas
[Applause]
training this morning yep now this is
the highest that tottenham i've been
anywhere in that perimeter in 16 years
feeling good feeling good well you're
not so funny
no no no chelsea now uh
what's the prediction who's gonna win
the league i think we've got a chance
yeah we've got a chance i think it's the
i think we have a better chance if you
play
more often try and try and i'm injured
in a moment but she'll be alright
ready what is it so just hamstring
that's a great one yeah but it should be
fine
are you seriously training this morning
yeah just in the gym oh great stuff a
little outside
yeah um now uh i'm done you'll ask i'm
obsessed with my kitchen at home but
apparently you have a hairdressing salon
in the basement of your house that's
right no you're the second person that's
it
it's a true little little barbers i
haven't actually built it yet but
you've got that
right okay our starters are made okay
and our dessert is nearly ready when
russell hopefully
hurries up the turkey's resting and our
potatoes are roasting nicely okay
let's see how are you doing how's the
trifle
uh it's still going all right golden
the custard looks liquid huh what about
this cream here
unbelievable uh max how are you doing
yeah yeah it's beautiful i've just got a
lovely bowl of scrambled eggs
which is going on top max all that money
you spent
on those cooking courses you can't make
custard max breezy come on
oh god
okay how are you maximum okay it's been
a long time since we spoke
getting there
so now it's time to get those starter
served and what you like putting food on
a plate
not too bad to be honest yeah really
smoked salmon
now kind of foods what do you enjoy
eating
i like salmon you like salmon here good
now
two plates i don't get that expensive
soup dirty so here's the trace right
okay come here dynamo is going to work
some magic if it doesn't work for you
now little shake get your fingers and
just pull down
okay and then from there bring it back
out and that's what i want there i think
i got it
beautiful beautiful huh
nice well done you've done this before
my mom's a chef so i want a little bit
of pressure
okay we've got to do it right everyone's
waiting for us in the dining room good
well done
you have done this before one on each
plate please
huh excellent now from there
okay take a little bit of your fennel
salad
yeah um are you good cook seriously do
you enjoy cooking
i don't mind here mm-hmm yeah i'm
playing i'm getting enough what kind of
things do you enjoy cooking
basic really like salmon pasta basic
stuff
great now chances for england to win the
european cup
come on please
i've got a chance he's got a chance
especially i think we're the young
players coming through now as well
yep now a little birdie told me this
morning
that you still go home to your mum's for
dinner come on oh she brings it to my
house
you get your mum to bring your dinner
always every sunday did you still do
your washing
no she doesn't she doesn't
okay right let's check in with arj how
are the starters going down
oh that one's ruins it's ruined
they are going amazing they are everyone
is loving them
uh apart from allergies which are ruined
what do you think
um you've been a food connoisseur for
many years
who's this better what one's better in
your opinion you're prosperous
incredible um i think lydia's looks more
intricate you know
what do you prefer first of all i think
i think debbie
thank you that won't even fill up my
little sister
uh welcome back well done lydia keep him
going please yes
yes uh max how's it going manchester
show me your salmon
okay big boy it's going extremely well
and then
obviously you know this lad here don't
you
that's scary very scary uh max
potatoes out the oven it's like having
you with me here baby it's beautiful
potatoes are still
um roasting off okay good make sure they
stay nice and crispy okay great
if you're running behind just turn up
the oven get them really nice and crispy
chats uh do you know what uh you look a
little bit scary max
unbelievable um i'm having him off i'm
not into him anymore
he's unbelievable he's taking his tats
off
i bet robbie wish you could do that um
is it true you're thinking of leaving
tottenham
no chance no chance no way
he's worse than me he's gonna move today
so this is good it was good
fantastic right time to serve yeah let's
go excellent
everyone at home serving starters here
we go guys right
off hayley ollie there we are
off you go i hope everybody's enjoying
their start as much as we are uh how was
that for you
that's fantastic actually you know what
the revelation is gordon is fantastic
reynolds salad light crisp oh it's
strawberry and
for the salad for a seller 10 smoked
salmon smoked salmon and stuff
well about seven about a seven thank you
ollie what would you give that
good good eight a good egg thank you
[Laughter]
come on come on
[Music]
okay right um i need some help with the
root badge please okay yeah
that was the last time you roasted some
veg when was that oh probably last week
actually
yes some lovely world slam
the sheep are just outside where i live
wow um along the druid estuary near port
marion
oh wow and it's just the most beautiful
beautiful land it's fabulous brilliant
brilliant brilliant
so veg we're going to roast the pasta
the carrots together okay
a couple of tablespoons of olive oil
carrots in please
be careful there's the carrots yeah no
we just roll them up
there you go nice right are they're
going to be done in time okay
give that a little salt and pepper
please russell with that thank you my
dad nothing
arge you're supposed to be doing your
veg now
lydia come on arge we're not finished
yet
dear oh dear the christmas lights are on
but archer's not at home
wow yeah give it a little whiz round
okay
good nice right from there a little bit
of cinnamon in there
okay cinnamon cinnamon
star nice and some nice thyme okay
so the idea here is to get them sort of
almost fragrant
roasted and then to get them really
caramelized russell
yeah a little touch of honey fantastic
so you're full of surprises young man
these flavors are beautiful i just want
to think the fact that you lost 11 stone
did you have to go out and buy a
complete new wardrobe
i mean well well no you know what it's
like when you
start off slim you don't throw anything
away
so you go up from like a 32 waist and i
went up to about a 56
waist and i'm now down to a 40 waist
that's okay so
i'm in the middle of the wardrobe i mean
that is fantastic honestly and you feel
better yeah well i mean the reason i
wanted to do strictly was because
i hated the gym and so dance is a great
way of actually losing weight so i was
doing a lot of disco standards said
look you can if i can do it okay welcome
back
trust me we are nearly there the veg are
in the oven make sure the oven's cranked
up to 220.
max bigly manchester how you doing
fantastic they sue you
uh seriously you got me worried with
those tattoos
okay oh no i'm not into it mate i'm not
into it
now max you know christmas day very
festive it's all about turkeys what's
the biggest
turkey you've made um the biggest turkey
i've made
probably going on the f-word
i mean the movies you've been in
oh i don't know tanya the milkmaid
can i just say max seriously that turkey
looks stunning
yeah right
look at that that is so succulent it's
moist i can't wait to get involved and
just heat it all up
listen max put the veg in the oven okay
leave the turkey rest in a brilliant
yeah okay great
right now dynamo is going to show us
some christmas magic
dynamite come on down bud should we get
jack in
jack come over buddy let's go he's a
massive fan of yours you know that
huh yeah right so um before we do this
actually i gave you a present when you
walked in you got it somewhere
it felt like uh it felt like a sort of
um a jumper can you hold it for right
now yeah
um you see i'm gonna take
can everyone see that they're different
yeah mm-hmm i'll put it up
jack brilliant jack just point to one
that one right there i'll do i don't
want us to look at it just yet
hold your hand up like this no one's
seen the card right
right now jack
your dad gets lots of presents every
christmas right for me everyone always
buys me a pack of cards
yeah is there any presents that everyone
always gets your dad um
opens yeah everywhere all right
i want you to open the present yeah and
you could have had to sell any present
there right you said an airplane
wow i've actually got you an airplane
wow wow wow that's a special airport
well
what no no it's got your face
and it's got one card on there yeah no
you could possibly any car we haven't
seen this card yet right
okay put the earphone on
should i won the card
unbelievable
that's fantastic hey christmas
uh jack were you in on that were you
were you part of that no
no no incredible how how how how
listen you give me cooking lessons and
we can talk
i'm not going to argue with that trust
me
[Music]
now if your potatoes are ready take them
out the oven if not leave them there for
3-4 minutes get really nice and crispy
we have some more babies being born
extraordinary big congressionalists to
sinead danny with baby logan just being
born in northern ireland amazing
congratulations emma and adam in
birmingham on their first baby holly
congratulations holly may
and congratulations to kazza harris
proud nana to hayden in london
unbelievable we're about to make the
brussels sprouts trust me we're nearly
there you're doing a great job let me
tell you turkey's resting potatoes are
rolling
the stuffing is ready put a frying pan
on get really nice and hot
we're going to saute the sprouts okay
you might look at me like that your kids
this is tilly
they talked about rival the christmas
tree what you just said
these are your children you bring them
up to dress me up look i'm sorry
i'm like a barbie to them pan on first
a little touch of salt in there okay
okay now we're going to part blanch
these sprouts okay
baby james yeah right just test it okay
now from there okay yeah close earrings
honestly
if you listen if you think this is going
to watch me on strictly tonight
did you perform yeah yeah i have an
explosive entrance
tonight were you upset with that early
exit no early i was in there for ten
weeks ten weeks really and if i hadn't
gone out at wembley then flavor and i
wouldn't have done the christmas special
tonight seriously
so it's worth it's worth it i went out
in the first round did you really
yeah was that dancing with the stars i
was happy to go out in the first round
but
why did you get kicked out so fast what
happened who knows
unbelievable what were you dancing
cha-cha-cha uh yeah no i
i no no i don't know what yeah it was a
cha-cha cha cha cha-cha
first one yeah
[Laughter]
it looks like wrestling not dancing
potatoes out the oven nice and crisp
okay you gave up on me now
okay from there what am i doing now okay
yeah
for the pan the reason here is one of
them you can stick those spouts in there
absolutely
yeah brussels brussels
right give that a little toss for me
there you go nice
good oh nice nice nice nut good i don't
know what the hell i'm doing
a touch of uh chili flakes in there
please huh yeah yeah
brilliant and some chili flakes it's
good that's garlic
garlic and some chili flakes there on
the left
side
just a touch nice uh half a big fan of
brussels
yes not anymore i know not since um um
brussels yeah the city the the country
but in bruges but not not
not after that last competition
yeah i mean the wind behind you always
be your own okay um
just think of this there's been a lot of
talk okay baywatch
yeah moving knight river movie who would
play you who would be a perfect actor
i don't know you know we're talking
about trying to bring knight rider back
as a film and i would even have somebody
play my son you know
that's like the top of my list right now
but could you see simon cowell playing
the knight rider
any spaghetti bear on michael you're
terrible driver
yeah no he actually cyber cal would be
actually a really good voice for kit
okay yeah yeah kind of the voice that
kind of you know
put you down you know type thing in a
cool way yeah
and how would that make you feel a movie
of something that was one of the most
watched tv shows anywhere in the world
well i'm trying to buy the rights to it
right now to make the film so
you know we're pretty close and a little
potential camera roll in there yeah
yeah no no i'll probably take the devon
character it'll be
michael knighton's son you know we go
out we will stay true to the original
which you have the heart
the humor in the action but you know
right now i'm you know i'm spending most
of my time here i live
and how about russell with a small
performance in the baywatch movie where
would he sit
um you know russell you could like you
could be like if you got like an evil
person
yeah you're good at evil yeah yes yeah
russell can you swim can you swim
over there can you swim no you can't
swim no i can't i wouldn't rest but
i couldn't dance before flash maybe i
could swim well if you're in the
baywatch movie and you were
you were drowning you didn't swim
you're driving you said lights on your
face the garlic's in there because of
the flavor the chili's in there got a
bit of heat
really important to get those lardons
really nice and crispy now cool
brussels we're going to drain them off
okay now here's the secret
um okay i used to get so frustrated with
mum putting a crisscross on the bottom
the secret is cut them in half squeeze
up the cooking process but more
importantly they stay together
give them a little shake and then add
them
into the lardons please straight in
please thank you
nice lovely well done right
ah gymnastics how are your brussels
uh lydia's taking control of the
brussels she's been doing that all
morning hard she's doing pretty good to
be honest with y'all
i know very well he's doing nothing it's
gonna be lonely for someone this
christmas
unbelievable it might be me at the
moment mate you're making me well jail
i know golden you will be when you taste
my parsnips make you be proper gel
if there's one parsley i don't want to
taste that it's yours let me tell you
[Music]
is it raining in manchester
it's raining cats and dogs and lardons
okay right now right give them a little
toss make sure they're nicely seasoned
take out that garlic okay
now put them into the dish okay stick
the dish in the oven
welcome back merry merry christmas what
an amazing day it's been crazy here
all those babies born across the country
merry merry christmas to you all right
first things first
reheat the gravy okay now put the gas on
bring the gravy up the ball just check
in the oven
you can never do enough check-in roast
sprouts are done
beautiful carrots parsnips roasting
stunning
right now arch
how the sprouts going yes sir
you tell me mate okay we've got two pans
of sprouts one's boiling one sauteing
lydia what's going on yeah the ones that
this was the ones that i did okay and
james was slow because he's been slow at
everything so he's
still on the boil okay potatoes look
gordon all right golden
yeah nice lydia this has really taught
me a lot you know
seriously i think it's taught us a lot
more
lydia are you thinking of changing your
mind on the back of his performance this
morning
you're not gonna marry him now surely i
definitely am golden
[Laughter]
are you going to be king of essex uh
well you know if people want to call me
that then they can call me that i don't
know i'm not going to give them the name
myself but
if people think it then i think it's
right i don't think debbie's convinced
fantastic max how's that gravy
oh it's um tackling i'm just removing
some of the uh
some of the wing that i left in there
earlier just to give it a bit of an
extra juju
that's gonna be great
unbelievable at max i heard this morning
that your mum has made backup dishes in
case things go wrong
is that true yeah well she normally
makes 18 dishes
yeah she makes 18 dishes each christmas
and today we're reduced to your stuff
but it is going to be amazing we are
actually tasting everything and it's
great mate how's the trifle looking
let me just show you that gordon just
come this way it looks like
please
uh max what have your guests thought of
the food so far how did the starter go
down well
why don't we ask them guys what did you
think of the starter that's absolutely
absolutely wonderful okay good
good good thanks to all my guests thanks
to arj and lydia in essex
and to maxine's family in manchester
it's been an amazing day
happy new year goodbye and merry
christmas and now it's time
to serve wow
[Music]
you